well I mean I was born in London but I'm
a come on a mutt my mother was born in
Kenya my father was born in Fiji my
ancestors are from India and yeah I grew
up in it in London and spent basically
most of my time in the in the basement
of the convenience store that my parents
ran
growing up in in Britain but as part of
a sort of South Asian Diaspora was big
in ways I didn't expect and there was a
sort of transformative moment for me
that I remember I think I was about six
years old and my parents had taken me
and my brother to India so that we would
know what it is to be Indian and we
would learn some Gujarati which is the
language that my parents spoke at home
and we were at a stoplight in Bombay I
think and we were inside a taxi and it
was raining
and all of a sudden there was this
knocking sound at the windows of
tap-tap-tap and outside of the window
was a girl I mean I imagine she was an
adolescent and in her hands was a tiny
baby and the baby was crying and crying
and crying and there was screaming
outside the car and she was tapping on
the window asking for money and soon
there was screaming inside the car
because I was howling I wanted it to
stop I wanted I wanted my parents to
give her some money and then as we sort
of drove away from the lights I kept on
howling and I I wanted to know why why
that was why was she out on the outside
of the car and why were we on the inside
why did she not have a home and we did
how comes we could afford to fly to
India and she could she was begging at a
streetlight now that kind of experience
I mean I I'm not trying to make myself
out as anyone special everyone has that
moment I mean but one of the most of
something you're guaranteed to hear in
any playground our howls of that's not
fair we all have that but for me that
moment never really left me I still
carry that little girl around with me
and after after that happened I went
back to Britain and you know I started
sort of renting out my toys to to my
friends and you know that their parents
would give them pocket money so that
they could play whatever toy it is that
I had and I would give that money to
charity to aid I mean the thing in the
news then was the the famine in Ethiopia
so he said
the money off to Ethiopia and I found
myself to be a sort of junior capitalist
turned philanthropist but you know
there's only so much toy rental that you
can do before you realize that actually
the problem is still there and being
exposed to the you know actually the
persistent problems in India year after
year make me realise that actually you
know the short-term fixes like sending
overseas aid while tremendously
important are not sufficient and you
need to get to the deeper root causes of
things and I studied in in in Britain
and in the United States and and in
South Africa both looking for those
answers and also learning from from
people who purported in some cases and
who actually did in other cases have
answers to how how to address the deeper
root causes of poverty
one of the things that I learned from
groups around the world particularly
looking at issues of hunger is that that
the root cause of hunger isn't that
there's a shortage of food there's more
than enough food on earth today to feed
everyone one and a half times over we've
got plenty of food on this planet but
the reason people are going hungry is
not because of a shortage of food um but
because of poverty so one of the them I
mean but people are not sitting sitting
idly by waiting for food to fall into
their laps you know the the there's I
mean there is that kind of vision and
particularly when we're thinking about
how how to change the world sometimes
you'll hear this this line of give a man
a fish and you feed him for a day but
teach a man to fish and you feed him for
a lifetime and I was gonna kind of get
behind I think yeah that's pretty cool
teach a man to fish for you feed him for
a lifetime but I mean the trouble is
think about what sort of image that that
rests upon I mean it has at heart the
idea that you know you've given a man
efficient a couple guys in the third
world somewhere sitting next to a
flowing river and they're chomping down
on their fish and they're enjoying their
face very much and they'll look over
into the river and say well what's that
it looks like a fish well how are we
gonna get it out oh I have no idea we
will have to wait for the white man to
come and give us another fish but it's
tremendously disempowering that's a nuts
vision of how things happen in
developing countries actually in
developing countries people in fishing
for a very very long time what the aid
complex and what a modern development
has done for developing countries is
impose a vision of how fishing should
happen and that that vision is very
unsustainable and it comes from outside
it comes from Europe it comes from North
America a vision that markets and free
markets and modern capitalism is going
to make life much much better and in the
process the ways that people have been
fishing the ways that social
organization has been managed are often
very sustainably is destroyed and swept
away now one of the the ways that people
have been fighting back is is through
organizing and developing their own
principles so that their own ways of
democratically or
and sharing resources and I was
privileged enough to come across a
number of farmers and farmers
organizations and landless people's
organizations that have been organizing
around the principle of how to feed
themselves and the the vision that they
have is a vision called food sovereignty
now food sovereignty is I mean the
definition is very long and if you're
interested go to Wikipedia and check out
food sovereignty and it's a great
definition um but in essence the idea of
food sovereignty is that people have the
ability to be able to make their own
decisions about food and agriculture
policy now that may not sound like
terribly much I mean the rights to be
able to make your own decisions about
food policy sounds pretty vapid it
sounds like well it's a right to have
rights over your food system it doesn't
seem to contain any policy but in fact
it does I mean it the the the the the
full definition of who-ville food
sovereignty demands that there are
things like women's rights being
respected and the agrarian reform so
that there's fair and equal land
distribution but but I mean the the
actual deep idea in the idea of food
sovereignty is that we need democracy in
shaping our food system we need a way of
actually everyone getting around the
table and having a conversation about
food and agriculture and the way that
people around the world to get to eat
and the way that the people around the
world get to develop and and realize
their full potential
now that turns out to be pretty radical
because as I say that the history of
food policy the history of agricultural
policy in poor countries has been one
where people from the outside will come
in teach people how to fish and will
teach people how to grow food or
essentially destroy the sustainable
agriculture that exists in developing
countries and replacing it with an
agriculture that at the moment is
looking increasingly unsustainable and
so having food sovereignty having a
democratic conversation about food is
actually pretty new most countries have
never had a democratic conversation
about food but
happened in the United States but pretty
much no country has had a decision attic
process where people decide well you
know how are we going to make sure that
everyone at a national level gets to eat
and that we distribute food fairly and
that we have sustainable agricultural
practices so that our kids will inherit
a planet and an agriculture system that
sustains them as much as it sustains
ours right now I mean we're on the brink
of basically emptying the oceans where
we're heading towards a climate change
catastrophe fueled and in no small part
by unsustainable agriculture that will
mean that in a couple of generations
time will there'll be nine billion
people on earth and a great deal more
hungry people than we have right now
food sovereignty is a way of
democratically getting us back onto a
track of sustainability
so this goes back to the question of how
a root cause is now I mean I'm I'm I'm
very keen to learn about ways in which
we can address the root causes of
poverty and when I was a graduate
student I was I was offered the
opportunity to to intern for him work
for the World Bank um and I was given
the opportunity to examine a range of of
classified World Bank documents to see
how the how the World Bank was talking
about poverty about the ways that it was
tackling the poor and I thought I'll do
that I mean classified documents an
insight into one of the world's largest
organizations had designed to tackle
poverty I'll do that now it turns out
that the examination of these documents
wasn't going to be a critical
examination of these documents instead
it turned out that those documents were
were used to create basically a sort of
puff piece called voices of the poor can
anyone hear us now I mean it's I mean
it's important to get a sense of what
the World Bank does and and and how it
operates and if you don't know anything
about the World Bank that there's a have
a small contribution to the world of
pedagogy in it and it relies on a
metaphor that comes from the Terry
Gilliam film Time Bandits now if you
don't know about time and time bandits
is a film about disgruntled former
employees of God now the story is that
God built the world in six days
so it was a rush job and God couldn't do
it all by himself he had help but he
treats his labor very badly and so they
run off with a map of the universe and
with its imperfections and they used the
holes in the universe to rob people and
so in one scene they robbed Napoleon and
they jump through a hole in time with
all Napoleon's stuff and they end up in
Sherwood Forest where they're met by
Robin Hood who's played by John Cleese
as a sort of upper class twit he's
wearing him there's a bright green hat
and he calls himself hood and hoods very
excited by all Napoleon stuff he says
well this is tremendous
thank you very much indeed I can say
that the poor will love this have you
met the poor the charming people of
course they don't have two pennies to
rub together but that's because they're
poor and there's a scene where
Napoleon's stuff is given away to the
poor and the poor are brought bring on
the poor and hood works the line and
he's killed in mirror for you yes how
long have you been poor
jolly good congratulations rubies for
you and right next to him is this big
hulking bloke who takes whatever hood
has given and punches the poor person in
the face so that's kind of how little
did the World Bank works it's it's it's
it's in the business of making these
these large loans but it is also a bank
so it takes those loans back and it
punches the punch in the face comes from
the policies that this organisation
imposes on developing countries policies
that have for example in agriculture led
to a decimation of agriculture in say
Africa this is not me making this
assessment in fact the World Bank a
couple of years ago admitted that it's
it's policies have been a disaster in in
in sub-saharan Africa now I say all this
because there is a sort of need within
the World Bank to have reassurance of
what it's doing is right a moment of
saying yet well some of our best friends
are poor people have you met the poor
that we had lunch with them yesterday
they loved us and that's what I ended up
doing my job was to be part of a
research team looking at these these
research reports on poverty and the the
the reports that we wrote that the
voices of the poor can anyone hear us
was basically a long way of for the
World Bank to say well have you met that
we had lunch with late the poor they
loved us and in fact the end of this
book was a long description about how
you know the consultants drove up in
their Jeep to the village and
spontaneously the women burst out in
song and thus they were singing here at
the World Bank here at the World Bank
they are here to develop us we hope they
won't forget us and the last line of the
book is will we and there's thing about
the the way the World Bank works I mean
it needs this kind of self-justification
don't get me wrong I mean
it's not like the world bank is filled
with evildoers a sort of Blofeld e'en
villains who are sitting in leather
chairs stroking cats thank you how are
we gonna the third world today it's
not like that I mean it's full of very
well-meaning people but they're
executing policies that are tremendously
bad for developing countries and the
thing is that as a citizen of Britain
and soon the United States that means
that this has been done in my name the
the European Union and the United States
are among the largest shareholders of
the United the World Bank and that means
that I am politically responsible for
that it's it's it's I mean the World
Bank policies are meant to be the
expression of the Democratic will of the
people of Britain and the United States
and actually taking political
responsibility for the damage that these
organizations have caused when doing
stuff in my name means that that at some
point you've got to you've got to get
out there and so I've protested the the
actions of the World Bank in in a number
of places and yeah I was lucky enough to
be part of the the World Trade
Organization process of it and that it's
an affiliated
ideologically affiliated organization is
the World Trade Organization and the
World Trade Organization protests in
Seattle in 1999 I was one of thousands
of organizers on the streets then
actually standing up against a certain
vision of what these organizations were
doing in our name against we were we
were standing up against those
organizations and those organizations
were pushing a development line a logic
about how the third world should work on
the third world in a tremendously
undemocratic fashion and so I mean right
now I think now is a good time to learn
democracy on the streets I mean that may
sound radical but when Al Gore is saying
that that now is the time for direct
action and when every movement of social
change in history has always been
achieved not through a ballot box but
but through people putting their bodies
on the line um I mean I think that in
order for our democracy to survive and
to flourish taking action against the
but against institutions that operate in
our name that are doing unjust things is
the right thing for any citizen to do
and unfortunately I've you know I've
been tear-gassed well you know a good
couple of times never arrested though
I've always managed to avoid that and
I've always actually every time I've
been tagged I said I was actually
assembling legally it was the police
that was responsible for getting out of
control
but I mean these have been some
experiences that that I mean I wouldn't
necessarily wish on anyone the tear gas
part but but the the demonstration part
and the marching together part was
amazing and and in fact it was in
Seattle in 1999 where I my first came
across the this is a full spectrum of
this organization called
la Via Campesina which is this
international peasant movement of a
hundred and fifty million farmers
landless rural workers and who have
members in many countries including the
United States in Canada throughout
Europe and of course Africa Latin
America and Asia and those moments of
learning on the street are that they are
tremendous they're a way of learning to
be a citizen learning to be a small d--
Democrat in a way that our schools and
our education system have really haven't
prepared us for we're not taught to be
citizens and I think that sometimes
protests can be a tremendous school for
learning how once you know how to begin
to take responsibility for ourselves
so I wrote the book the value of nothing
because it's very clear that markets
have failed us I mean the financial
crisis is just one of a number of crises
that we've gone through over the past
few years we had the food crisis we had
the oil crisis and the bubbles in
markets are obviously part of those
markets that they're endemic to the way
markets function and right now is a very
good time for thinking about other ways
in which we can value the world what we
don't have is a real understanding about
how to value the world other than
through markets other than by sticking a
price on something but I mean I mean the
sad thing of course is that even when we
do stick a price on something we still
have no idea what that price means I
mean yeah I think a Martian would find
it very weird that one of the most
popular game shows in in the US and
around the world is the price is right
where people have to guess the price of
something and you know guess wildly up
and down until late yeah until they win
the thing that they've approximated the
price to prices are a mystery to us in
general um but what's more mysterious to
us is what other ways of valuing the
world and so what I try and do in the
value of nothing is kind of explain
firstly why it is that we've been sucked
into this way of thinking about prices
and then try to figure out a way or show
that the many ways that already exists
that we can behave differently and one
of the metaphors that I use is this idea
of Anton's blindness now Anton's
blindness is a rare neurological
condition it happens after a stroke or a
traumatic brain injury and it's a weird
condition where you believe that you can
see whereas in fact you are blind so you
people who have Anton's blindness will
will protest that they can see stuff so
sometimes very strange stuff you know
sort of odd people walking through or a
housing development right outside their
window they could have sworn wasn't
there yesterday but but in fact they're
cortically blind and the way that you
can diagnose this is when for example
people with Anton's blindness run into
stuff because obviously they're blind
they'll bump their their toe on
something and then they will confabulate
they will make stuff up about how oh I
didn't see that there
I've no idea that someone rearranged the
room when I wasn't looking
and these confabulations these ways of
self-justifying sometimes elaborate
stories about why things that people
protest to see are but but in fact
aren't there whatwhy reality and their
vision of the world have clashed so so
horribly these confabulations these
stories are a way of diagnosing the
disease now in many ways the way that
we've behaved around the the financial
crisis has been oh god well yeah we
should have seen that coming and what
we'll need now is just better regulation
we'll pad things out and it'll make the
world a better place um
now obviously regulation is important
but that we shouldn't I mean I think we
should use the opportunity right now is
actually to get slightly deeper into the
problem of figuring out other senses
figuring out other ways in which we can
value the world other than through the
faulty prism of markets and luckily
enough there are loads of ways in which
we can value the world I mean in fact
the most recent Nobel Prize in Economics
was awarded in part to Professor Elinor
Ostrom
who is a professor of economics at
Indiana University who's been who has
proved a long time done work on
something called the Commons now the
Commons I mean I had no idea what the
Commons meant originally and I grew up
in Britain where the House of Commons is
basically a rowdy white men's drinking
club and although that the boundaries of
that have been pushed a little bit it's
still a drinking Club and mmm when I
first came to America and and my we were
on holiday in New York and my parents
were told oh you must go to Woodbury
Common and and we went to Woodbury
Common which which turns out to be this
huge outlet mall in New Jersey and I
thought common it was just American for
shopping but it turns out that Commons
is I mean an ancient and venerable and
also a currently existing way to not
only
delineate a set of resources but also to
share them sustainably and to maintain
them and commoning which is the sort of
process of managing these natural
resources invariably natural resources
in common and within a community that's
an amazing way of valuing the world that
doesn't revolve around markets and
prices but does revolve around political
participation and engagement now I mean
that that may sound horribly distant to
what we have at the moment to the world
that we live in right now um but it
doesn't mean it what's inspiring I think
I'm what what's important to remember is
that there are hundreds of examples
thousands of examples where commenting
works today and in the book I talk a lot
about what those examples are and how we
can learn from
so the title of the value of nothing
comes from an Oscar Wilde line which is
nowadays people know the price of
everything and the value of nothing and
this an idea of knowing prices he's you
know what when I'm gonna start again
because that was boys don't me to some
extent I kind of feel like I've said a
little bit I mean I've kind of talked
about that already okay but I mean I can
I can take that I can take that slightly
different direction which is um so the
opening line of the book I don't find
the title the value of nothing comes
from an Oscar Wilde line people today
know the price of everything and the
value of nothing now in the book I
explained how we might value the world
differently but it's not an accident
that I use Oscar an Oscar Wilde line I
mean beyond the fact that he's very
clever um
Oscar Wilde was a socialist and you know
in the early 20th century and pretty
much anyone who was anyone was socialist
imijo anyway everyone from sort of
Albert Einstein to Helen Keller
socialist and I think that it's
important to remember that there have
been political systems that have valued
the world differently and figured out
ways of valuing the world differently
that have been erased by the sort of
triumph of capitalism by the fall of the
Soviet Union and in fact those political
systems although we hear very little
about them are still alive and well and
people do have visions of sharing the
world perhaps not along the lines of
classical the sort of Soviet politics
and thank God they don't have those
kinds of lines but there are
alternatives that are around us that are
kind of suppressed that I hidden and I
have no doubt that when people read the
book and finds that actually I'm not
entirely critical of Karl Marx they will
they will sort of froth at the mouth and
brand me a communist um but you know
like Oscar Wilde like Albert Einstein
like like a bunch of people throughout
history I mean yeah I'm not a communist
I'm just open-minded and I think that
it's it's important to have a
look at other ways of valuing the world
particularly when we're living as Lord
Nicholas Stearns has said in right now
in the greatest market failure in human
history the way that we failed to value
the climate and the environment it means
that we are heading towards a
catastrophe of immense proportions and
and we do need to figure out other ways
of valuing the world and actually there
are some pretty sensible alternatives
around if people are ready to be
open-minded
I'm sure I think of what what the what a
good example is so what would it look
like to have a world where we where we
valued things and where it wasn't the
market that was allocating resources
according to supply and demand but but
but there were other forces at work well
what one example in fact an example that
that's springing up all over the world
now is something called participatory
budgeting and this happens at a
municipal level it was pioneered in
Brazil where the Workers Party kind of
pushed it in and and and the the the
vision is that when when a city is
deciding how to spend its money wouldn't
it be a good idea if the citizens of
that city were part of that decision as
opposed to sort of faceless bureaucrats
who following some formula or who are
corrupt in some way making making
spending allocations according to
whoever bribed them the most
so participatory budgeting is a very
interesting way of assigning and
allocating resources that have nothing
to do with money I mean usually the the
the ways that these budgeting decisions
are taken are by the poorest people in
the city who gets together in local
assemblies and then those those
decisions are communicated up into
citywide assemblies um now if we were
going to allocate resources purely
according to the basis of an ability to
pay
then the city's poorest residents
wouldn't be able to afford those
resources but because those resources
are controlled democratically um poor
people can make decisions about well you
know we want a school here we want a
hospital here we want we want it
sequenced in this order because this
would be fairest and this would be you
know who cover the most people and
people taking political responsibility
for themselves and and actually engaging
in democracy is I mean we get it we can
get a taste of what valuing looks like
under that process by looking at things
like participant RIBA cheating which we
know which we find not only in Brazil
now but actually in a number of places
across the world um and this is
interesting because this gets us into
this into a question about democracy and
about what democracy is
and one of the things that I'm I mean I
I think is important for us to recognize
is that pretty much none of us live in a
democracy we live in a kind of complain
aqua sea where if we whine loudly enough
then the bastards who are in charge of
us can be replaced by different bastards
who are in hock to slightly different
interests and who will run the
government in slightly different ways
but they're essentially sort of
following that the same kind of plan um
but that's not really what democracy
like is like and if you go back to the
original democracy if you go back to
Athens classical Athens had obviously
let's get out of the way the fact that
yes there was slavery in Athens and yes
women were excluded and I mean Athenian
democracy isn't something one wants to
replicate but it is something to learn
from because Athenian democracy worked
like this there were no elections in
Athenian democracy instead 6000 citizens
were chosen at random at the beginning
of every year to take charge of the city
and they would be split up into groups
of 500 and those 500 sort of courts of
citizens would be the law for a whole
year and then at the end of the year the
another 6000 people would be chosen
again at random and it was every
citizens duty to take responsibility for
the voting effort for themselves and for
their fellow citizens and people who
didn't want to do this we're called
idiots I mean this is one of the
original ideas of Athenian democracy of
democracy itself is that it's it's part
of the the the obligation and the duty
of every citizen and the privilege of
every citizen to be able to to be able
to clean up after yourself I mean yeah
we all we all know about sort of
personal responsibility and personal
hygiene and we're encouraged to buy the
right thing and shop the right shop in
the right place and get around by the
right kinds of transportation but as
soon as we try and take political
responsibility people look at you like
just like you're bonkers but I mean if
you're I mean if we're concerned about
democracy then that's exactly what
democracy is about democracy is about
taking personal responsibility for
yourself in a political way and Athenian
democracy was all about that and I think
that
we have at the moment is intended to
descale us that the education system we
have the the mechanisms for political
process and engagement that we have are
intended really to turn us into in terms
of drooling idiots when it comes to
political responsibility and I think
that there are movements and
organizations around the world that
offer us a glimpse into what it would be
like if we did take political
responsibility for ourselves and they're
not perfect and people make mistakes but
of course that's the point what in many
ways we're fighting for is the right to
make our own mistakes because at the
moment we're suffering the consequences
of other people's mistakes and democracy
means getting the right to make your own
clean up after yourself and learn from
it right now we spend a lot of time
cleaning up after a handful of sort of
plutocrats and I think actually getting
democracy back involves reom powering
ourselves to be able to make our own
mistakes and to learn from them
it was very interesting in at the end of
2008 to see Alan Greenspan looking
basically looking pretty hungover
appearing in front of the House
Oversight Committee where he was grilled
about you know why the financial crisis
was happening happening um yeah and I
mean you you can forgive him for looking
a little Haggard because I mean the the
the party had lasted for several decades
I mean the the party of free markets
uber alles free markets being able to be
the absolutely the best way of
organizing the world and you know what
Alan Greenspan was forced to admit is in
his words I have found a flaw in the
ideology that I thought was responsible
for the functioning of the world and
that's an odd I mean that's a fairly
profound admission from one of the
pioneers of this kind of kooky
free-market libertarianism that where
Alan Greenspan of course is sort of
famously a disciple of Ain Rand and you
know the Rand's ideas about sort of
free-market libertarianism that the
entrepreneurs should lead the society
out of the Dark Ages and any kind of
organizing was parasitic on society any
kind of social justice organizing was
destructive to society those kinds of
ideas are ones that Alan Greenspan
more or less faithfully embodied in his
pushing of the free market um and at the
end of 2008 it all came crashing down
now one of the reasons that I wrote this
book is firstly to show how those ideas
ascended and why they inevitably came
apart at the fell to pieces but also I
mean it's a way of saying look actually
that there was a few decades where that
the sort of free market fundamentalists
were able to take control of the economy
and it's gonna be very hard to pry the
pry their hands off it um but there are
ways of actually reclaiming our economy
from the
these ideologues and and those ideas are
you know to be found in everything from
you know so worker owned cooperative
stew yeah I mean I but a banking and
finance that he's that performs a social
function rather than a speculative
function there are loads of different
ways in which we can get the economy
back from the the sort of corruptions of
this the zany free-market idea that has
never achieved never that never happened
in in practice and that this seriously
theoretically flawed and again I mean in
in in the book I talk about how for
example I mean even Adam Smith who's the
poster child for free market ideas Adam
Smith never thought the free market was
unfettered free market was a good idea
he saw a strong role for government he
saw a strong role for sort of
self-improvement for education for a
certain kind of moral conscience and
that you know that you will find no room
for in in in in the most sort of extreme
dogma of the free-market libertarians
and so it's important to remember that
and important to actually plunder
history but for lessons that we have
that are well worth learning for as we
try and build a better economy and right
now's a good time to be thinking
learning those lessons and thinking
about how we can restructure things
because as we come out of the recession
and you know although we're told that
recovery is on its way I mean
unemployment is still going to climb
over the next couple of years and no one
pretends that for the poorest Americans
things are going to get better for the
richest Americans things are starting to
turn around but for the poorest things
are gonna get worse for a good good two
three years at best and I think now's a
good time to be thinking about well
actually if if we're not part of the
plutocracy well what what do we want and
what can we learn from the past to make
sure that we these mistakes never happen
again
my my first book was called stuffed and
starved and it the title comes from a
strange paradox that we live in a world
where today over a billion people are
malnourished and going hungry and at the
same time more than a billion people are
overweight and what I tried to do in the
book is is explain how it is that not
only that these two things are possible
simultaneously but how they are outcomes
of the same system so let's I mean first
aren't let's let's just understand the
dynamic here and actually you don't have
to go to Africa I mean you one could
imagine that the starving are in Africa
and the you know the the the obese are
in America I mean to some extent that's
true
the United States is the most obese
country on earth and only four out of
ten Americans are have a normal body
weight and the rest of us are a little
portly but but the the the the the fact
is that there is hunger in America as
well in 2008 forty nine million
Americans were food insecure they didn't
know it during the year where their next
meal was coming from so it's possible to
have hunger hunger and obesity in the
same country at the same time and it's
possible to have hunger in in in the
United States even when there's an
abundance of food and you know I mean
it's not like in 2008 the shelves were
emptied in the United States but what
happened was the price of that food went
up and the incomes of people went down
and that's why people go hungry in
America it's not because of some
Malthusian shortage of food it's because
of poverty now the AMIA that's so the
question that i ask is is about well how
do we get the situation and also how do
how do we get these outcomes of hunger
and obesity well the hunger is easy to
explain
hunger obtains when as I say people are
too poor to be able to afford the food
that is around them um and the majority
of the the hungriest people on earth
today live in rural areas that this is a
strange paradox that the people who are
the hungriest on earth tend to be the
people involved in agriculture
and farm but particularly farm laborers
farm workers and what I try and show in
the book is how the people who are
growing the food are intimately
connected to the people who consume the
food through a kind of hourglass figure
so if you imagine the millions of
farmers on earth who grow food for us
the wheat and then at the bottom that
the six nearly 7 billion of us who eat
every day but it's an hourglass figure
because there are millions of farmers
billions of us but just a few
corporations in the Middle's egg so it
comes in like this and goes back out
again a few corporations controlling the
majority of whatever corner of the food
market you care to mention I mean you
know in in the packaged tea business a
one corporation Unilever controls 96% of
the world's package tea one corporation
90% ninety-six percent of the world's
market but in every major market there's
a handful of corporations that are
basically run the show now those
corporations have every incentive to pay
the people who are growing the food as
little as they possibly can and to sell
the food in ways that guarantee the
maximum amount of profit and that means
selling foods that is processed that is
high in the sorts of things that make us
buy more food so high in salt and fat
and sugar the kinds of things that our
bodies are hard-wired to crave and so
you end up in a situation where the
corporations pay that the the farm work
is a pitifully little end up selling us
food that is obesogenic that makes us
that that makes us fat that makes us
crave more of the food that makes us eat
in unhealthy ways and you end up in us
in a world where you have billions of
people what over a billion people who
are overweight and as I say millions of
now over a billion people starving and
again the key factor here is poverty now
it used to be that if you were fat you
were rich and if you were poor if you're
if you're hungry you and if you were
sort of stick thin and then you were
poor but these days are increasingly in
particularly in rich countries obesity
and hunger are two sides of the same
coin
obesity and hunger are as both symptoms
of one more extreme than the other of an
inability to control your diet an
inability to be able to muster
enough resources to be able to eat
healthily and sustainably and in a way
that is good for your body and it turns
out that there are ways in which we can
eat sustainably the ways that we can
actually
rebalance the food system and connects
directly with the people who grow the
food that cut out the the sort of
bottleneck of the hourglass but then
involves some some profound social
change